♪ ♪ ♪
STÉPHANE MALO
- Ça, ça pèse rien, je vais
mettre mon petit "trailer" sur
mon quatre-roues.
- Stéphane Malo est un maniaque
de pêche, il nous montre
avec fierté sa toute nouvelle
embarcation. Un zodiac qui n'a
rien à voir avec sa chaloupe
de 16 pieds avec laquelle il
a navigué pendant des années.
- Elle représentait tout, ce
bateau je l'ai aimé comme ça se
peut pas. Je l'ai vendu, plus
capable de sortir nul part
sans se faire exploiter
en payant des prix de fou
aux descentes de bateaux.
Moi je suis résident
de Chertsey, il y a deux lacs
que j'aimerais pêcher. J'ai pas
d'accès parce que je ne suis
pas riverain, c'est très
dommage. J'ai une maison, notre
maison... on paie des taxes,
j'ai pas accès.
C'est pas normal.
- Et ils sont nombreux, comme
lui, à déplorer cette situation.
JACQUES VADEBONCOEUR
- C'était comme un retour au
club privé.
- Jacques Vadeboncoeur est
un habitué des plans d'eau
depuis plus de 50 ans.
- Au début des années 90, je
venais ici, c'était gratuit
pas mal partout ici.
À Varennes, c'est rendu un prix
exorbitant.
À Pointe-des-Cascades,
c'est rendu payant.
STÉPHANE BOURGEOIS, Prés. asso.
des pêcheurs sportifs du Québec
- Ça va de pire en pire, là,
je vous dirais qu'alentour
de Montréal, c'est presque 90%
des accès qui sont rendus
payants. Il y a plusieurs villes
qui interdisent l'accès aux
non-résidents. D'autres villes
interdisent l'utilisation
de moteurs à essence. D'autres
villes chargent 300 $, 400 $,
500 $, par jour.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Stéphane Bourgeois milite
depuis plus de 10 ans pour
améliorer l'accessibilité
aux plans d'eau, mais l'enjeu
est complexe. En général, tous
les plans d'eau de la province
sont sous juridiction
provinciale et fédérale, mais
se sont les municipalités qui
en gèrent l'accès.
- Je me rends compte que ce
n'est pas simple, il y a
des conflits d'usage, il y a
les résidents qui veulent
de la tranquillité, il y a des
gens, des plaisanciers, eux
autres ils veulent faire du
bruit, mettre de la musique dans
le tapis puis faire de la vague,
puis il y a des pêcheurs qu'eux
autres bien nous on n'est comme
plus tranquilles là, on fait pas
pout pout pout. C'est essayer
de faire plaisir à tout
ce monde-là, de concilier
tout le monde.
- Ici à Rosèmère, l'afflux
de plaisanciers au cours de
la dernière année a poussé
le maire à privatiser
les deux accès à la rivière
des Milles Iles
sur son territoire.
ÉRIC WESTRAM
MAIRE DE ROSEMÈRE
- Le parc Charbonneau ici qui
est un superbe endroit s'est
fait envahir, les gens pique-
niquent. Les gens avec des
les embarcations, ils se sont
rendu compte que toutes
les embarcations à moteur,
au niveau biodiversité,
au niveau de gestion
d'érosion des rives et tout ça,
c'est très mauvais
pour l'environnement.
- La protection des lacs est
aussi au coeur de cet enjeu.
- Les municipalités sont
très frileuses aux espèces
exotiques envahissantes,
elles veulent avoir le moins
possible d'étrangers sur leurs
lacs, nous ce qu'on leur dit,
c'est que oui on est conscients
qu'on peut transporter
des espèces exotiques et
envahissantes, mais il faut
prendre les moyens pour laver
les embarcations.
DANIE DESCHÊNES, mairesse Notre
Dame-de-l'Ile-Perrot
- On considère que tout le monde
devrait avoir accès à l'eau.
- La mairesse de Notre-Dame-
de-l'ile-Perrot a inauguré
la semaine dernière la première
rampe de mise à l'eau, publique
et accessible
aux non-résidents, la seule
sur son territoire. Et il a
fallu 12 ans.
C'est assez compliqué avoir
une autorisation aujourd'hui, en
2021, tout simplement parce que
les normes environnementales
ont beaucoup changé, mais aussi
les exigences. Les villes font
face à un défi financier,
alors ça prend beaucoup
d'investissements pour gérer
une descente à l'eau.
- Cette rampe lui a coûté au
final près de 80 000 $.
- Est-ce que vous aimeriez que
Québec vous donne un coup
de main?
- Bien, c'est sûr! (rires).
C'est certain que l'aide
du gouvernement serait
la bienvenu parce que c'est
un service à la population
en général et donc ça serait
très apprécié.
Comment cohabiter ensemble
sur les plans d'eau?
Le gouvernement de la CAQ avait
promis en campagne électorale
de s'attaquer aux problèmes.
- Pour Stéphane, la solution est
simple : il faut réapprendre
à partager les plans d'eau.
La mentalité des riverains,
c'est mon lac, tu 'as pas
d'affaire ici, ça c'est partout
au Québec, pas juste à Chertsey,
c'est partout au Québec, ça il
faut casser cette mentalité-là.
Ici, Marie-Michelle Lauzon
Radio-Canada, M